dating is hard I hear it all the time
from women I'm dating but I'm still
trying I'm out all the apps OkCupid
tinder venmo trivago all of them not a
single byte I don't get it
what's going on is it me is it my looks
is it my pet Python in my profile pic or
does it go deeper than that here to
break down the politics of the modern
dating landscape a citizen journalist
and conservative commentator Nicole
Thurmond welcome welcome Nicole no
what's going on here why is a great guy
like me having such a hard time getting
a date okay one word Jorden
discrimination conservatives are under
attack they hate our guns they hate our
freedom and now they hate our love take
a look a new survey from time out found
a third of people in the dating pool
will not date a conservative some will
even go as far as to google them to see
if they have any affiliations with the
Trump campaign did you hear that Jordan
one-third of people refuse to date
conservatives are they crazy
have they seen Sean Hannity and blue
jeans oh man it really fills out those
5:05 he does and their politicizing
dating now the other day I saw a real
article that was actually titled
including the emojis how come nobody
wanna PC conservative yeah yeah yeah how
come okay fine yep
you know liberals are always having
their traps about inclusion and
acceptance but when it comes to dating
they are so closed-minded not like me
mm-hmm
I've asked out a ton of libs I asked out
of white barista who had dreadlocks
Jordan white dreadlocks he played in a
band that was just rain sticks I asked
out I asked out a Bernie bro
okay I even tried to date a Mumford and
a son that is two different people and
six mandolins okay the point is I put
myself out there but now progressives
are putting up all these walls that is
not okay walls are our thing agreed that
is shameful Nicole yeah and the discrim
nation just gets worse check this out
the dating and networking app Bumble is
banning profile images that include guns
from its nearly 30 million users the
austin-based company says the move comes
in the wake of mass shootings and gun
violence Wow no glock pics come on how
will I know my due believes in
supply-side economics if I can't see his
beretta now I gotta say it's starting to
sound like there's no hope out there for
real Americans like us no let's stop
cryin Jordan there is always hope
conservatives are crafty they saw what
was happening with all those other
sights and decided to make one of their
own check it out a new website promising
to quote make dating great again it's
called Trump dating and it matches Trump
supporting singles together it says
having matching political and patriotic
viewpoints as it puts it our foundations
in a relationship but it also says only
straight people are welcome to join okay
well I mean the site does sound great
but it seems kind of unfair to exclude
gay Trump supporters right um totally
and I feel super bad for Kevin but
the rest of us you know for the rest of
us Trump dating is awesome
in fact it's so awesome that lefties are
trying to take it down
you see liberals hate the idea of
conservatives finding love and making a
new generation of little Trump babies so
they're already nitpicking every little
flaw with Trump dating like this one
itsy bitsy teeny little thing a man
whose photo was used for a dating site
for trump supporters has been revealed
as a convicted felon for sex with a
child okay so the original poster boy
for Trump dating with a child sex
offender like whatever I mean I hear
Mark Zuckerberg has an unpaid parking
ticket and he's a murderer really
I don't know spread it yeah will do